pourquoi g et de la réputée firme tout
juste arrivé de france ces infirmières
sont en formation elles ont fait le saut
malgré la crise qui sévit au québec
effrayé un petit peu mais après en
france c'est pareil au final les
infirmières sont sous pression les
hôpitaux sont sous pression la chose
peut paraître étonnante mais en europe
la pratique infirmière au québec aurait
encore une image très favorable
on parle beaucoup de la pratique aussi
et ça encore une très bonne image il ya
des groupes avec des milliers de
personnes qui parlent tous les jours
qu'ils me demandent des conseils pour
venir vivre ici tant mieux parce que
c'est étrangères sont devenus essentiels
pour les infirmières depuis cinq ans la
proportion des diplômés hors québec a
doublé en 2010 est ça représentait 11%
du total l'an passé on avait atteint 22%
le réseau québécois est maintenant
devenu dépendant de ces professionnels
venus d'ailleurs parce que les besoins
sont trois importants puis c'est
vraiment une main-d'oeuvre qu'on peut
plus passer cette année la moitié des
nouveaux employés du sud du nord de
l'île de montréal seront recrutés à
l'étranger des infirmières mais aussi
des technologues et des travailleurs
sociaux on a vraiment un objectif
d'embaucher au moins 250 ressources
étrangères rien que l'année prochaine
mais quand je dis ressources et des
travailleurs sociaux des infirmiers pour
y arriver le sud du nord de l'île de
montréal créé son propre bureau
d'immigration qui compte cinq employés
on s'est dit il faut créer un bureau du
recrutement pour vraiment les intégrer
les suivre dans leur cheminement
d'immigration si je vous dis si hsbc est
ce que ça vous dit quelque chose en plus
de la formation aux pratiques il y à la
théorie sur le fonctionnement du réseau
québécois et ces acronymes souvent
complexes mais on offre aussi de
l'accompagnement pour les écoles ou
encore le logement
sont bien intégrés d'un adapté qui ont
vraiment le soutien nécessaire parce que
tout n'est pas rose ces infirmières
découvre rapidement les irritants locaux
ici le médecin de famille on n'en a pas
tout de suite allé à l'urgence soit dans
très longtemps là c'est au médecin ça
reste une chose qui est bas du cou très
compliqué ça m'a un peu porté par
rapport à la france toutes les régions
du québec sont engagés dans une course
aux talents à l'étranger lesieu zh du
nord de l'est de montréal espère être en
tête est-ce qu'il va y avoir de la
concurrence peut-être je pense qu'il
faut pas qu'on se le cache par rapport à
l'évaluation des dossiers à savoir
comment on y trouve ici david gêne-t-il
et radio canada montréal